[Music]
for anyone interested
we just recently released our very first
piece of harry potter theory merchandise
it features an adaptation of our
favorite ps1 gameskeeper
and links to the merch can be found just
below the video
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in today's video i'm going to be
discussing the mirror of erised
sirius black and the betrayal of the
potters
more specifically i'm going to be
discussing what alleged
notorious mass murderer sirius black
would see in the mirror
we know sirius black primarily as
harry's godfather
and one of the marauders a childhood
group comprised of black
peter pettigrew remus lupin and james
potter
sirius started at the hogwarts in the
year 1971
and met the boys that would form the
marauders in that same year
they were a group of gryffindors
hell-bent on breaking the rules at the
school
and were notorious for their mischief
making however
despite getting up to all kinds of
trouble they were all very magically
talented
after graduating from the school the
four boys even went on
to join the order of the phoenix in an
effort to oppose the regime
of lord voldemort sirius hailed from the
powerful wizarding family the blacks
and while many of his family members
placed an unreasonable amount of value
on blood purity sirius did not share the
same belief
he was an easy going guy compared to
them and managed to avoid going down a
dark path
even if he was blamed for being evil
anyway
sirius was notoriously known for his
imprisonment in azkaban prison
and spent a considerable amount of time
there for crimes that he didn't actually
commit
in 1981 peter pettigrew backstabbed the
potters
by revealing their location to lord
voldemort he was their chosen
secret keeper and he betrayed everyone
when he decided to relay that
information
to lord voldemort however that wasn't
all he did that day
he also framed his childhood friend
sirius black
for a heinous crime you see after
betraying the potters
sirius and pettigrew had an altercation
an altercation in which petty crew
murdered 12 muggles using a dark and
powerful blasting curse
simultaneously destroying hundreds of
feet of sewer system
and leaving a 40-foot crater in the
ground someway
somehow sirius black was blamed and was
promptly sent to azkaban
after being banished to azkaban
seemingly the whole world
turned on sirius even the ghost portrait
of the fat lady
and he was left there to rot for an
astonishing 12 years
he was eventually able to escape the
iron fortress by turning into his
animagus form
a black dog and squeezing through the
bars at this point in time
he was able to re-establish a
relationship with harry
but still tragically lost many years of
his life to prison
sirius was a good man with good morals
and the fact that he was able to deviate
from the path that members of his family
traditionally took
speaks to that he was a balanced
self-aware man
that even once made the wise statement
we've all got both light and dark inside
us
what matters is the part we choose to
act on that's who we really are
so what you may ask now would the man
who suffered tragedy after tragedy
see in the mirror of herrera said let's
dive in
a brief recap on the mirror of erised
it's a magical mirror that shows us the
deepest most desperate desires of our
hearts this is reflected
in the mirror's name no pun intended as
error said flipped around
reads as desire the mirror itself was
made sometime before the end of the 19th
century
and is located in the room of
requirement in hogwarts
so what is sirius's greatest deepest
desire
what would he see i think that if sirius
were to look into the mirror of erised
he would see himself with the potters
the same night that he advised them to
make peter pettigrew
secret keeper except instead of
recommending pettigrew for the job
he would have been secret keeper himself
james lilly and harry
would all still be a family safe and
secure
lily and james only made you secret
keeper because i suggested it i thought
it was the perfect plan
voldemort would be sure to come after me
would never dream they'd use a weak
talentless thing like you it must have
been the finest moment of your miserable
life
telling voldemort you could hand him the
potters you see
advising the potters to make pettigrew
secret keeper was the biggest mistake he
ever made
it was the decision that led to the
murder of his best friends
and it was also the decision that
ultimately landed him in azkaban
that single false recommendation was the
catalyst for an incredible amount of
death
heartache and suffering and it was
likely the only thing
that sirius could ever think about a
constant sharp pain
in cirrus's conscience in a perfect
world
given the opportunity i think that
sirius would have gone back in time
to the day that he made that poor
recommendation and instead
would have assumed the role of secret
keeper himself
the only good thing that came from
pettigrew being secret keeper
was that it ultimately led to
voldemort's destruction for a time
though whether that could have been
achieved with less suffering is
untelling
what do you guys think sirius black
would have seen in the mirror of error
said
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
you think the dead we loved ever truly
leave us